good morning everyone first I'd like to
thank the organizers for inviting me
here today I'm going to talk about
biomarkers cognition and cognitive
reserve in Alzheimer's disease as
everybody knows the pathological cascade
and Alzheimer's disease consists of
upstream pathological processes causing
downstream cognitive decline and the
area shown in red here is really
important when subjects move from
cognitively normal to cognitive
impairment to dementia because that
gives us an insight of the disease as
well this helps us understand the ways
in which we can delay the onset of the
disease so the prime area of my research
has been to study the effect of
protective mechanisms in Alzheimer's
disease so we know that pathology causes
downstream cognitive decline and the
goal of my work has been how do
protective mechanisms help delay the
onset is it by directly improving
someone's cognition is it directly by
reducing the amount of pathology that is
deposited in the brain or is it somehow
interacting with pathology together to
improve cognition in a person the
overview of my talk is as follows first
will become start with biomarkers of
Alzheimer's disease
next we'll move on to pathological or
biomarker cascade in Alzheimer's disease
where we studied the relationship
between biomarkers and cognition and
third we'll talk about cognitive reserve
or the protective mechanism and how does
it influence the biomarker cascade and
what we can do to slow down the
progression of the disease beginning
with the first part when we begin with
biomarkers and Alzheimer's disease
I wanted to show you the NIH definition
of a sinus disease biomarkers which is
it needs to be a characteristic that is
objectively measured and evaluated as an
indicator of normal biological processes
pathogenic processor or pharmacological
responses to a therapeutic intervention
so for something to qualify as a
biomarker for Alzheimer's disease it
needs to measure the underlying
pathologies as well
we need to use the existing technology
in order to develop these biomarkers the
two pathologies that on Elias Amish
disease that need to be measured are
amyloid plaques shown by the new
neurotic plaque picture here as well as
neuronal injury neuronal injury consists
of new fabric tangles shown in the
picture here as well as neuro
degeneration which is a curing of the
brain structures due to loss of neurons
and synapses the typical biomarkers and
Alzheimer's disease that are considered
for clinical trials and observational
studies are two two classes first is
amyloid plaques PET scans with amyloid
racers as well as CSF levels CSF a beta
1 2 4 2 levels are used to measure the
degree of amyloid plaques in the brain
I'll show you a few examples of how the
PET scans look and then the second class
of biomarkers are neuronal injury
biomarkers which are used to measure CSF
total power levels in the CSF as well as
fdg-pet scans are used to measure
neuronal injury as well as structural
MRI scans so one thing to consider when
you're using biomarkers in Alzheimer's
disease is the fact that biomarkers are
continuous but we need cut points in the
clinic for biomarker positivity so that
we can apply them and use them to treat
patients so beginning with the first
class of biomarkers that is amyloid
scans along mr. C spectrum so as I said
as amyloid pet
tracers measure brain am Lord load by
binding to the fibrin a beta and the
three common compounds that are
currently used the first one that was
developed in 2004 was Pittsburg compound
B or pip scans and the two recent ones
is your f-18 based our floor beta per
and flew to madam all scans so you for
you to appreciate how big scans look we
try to create a series of scans of
subjects along this Alzheimer's disease
spectrum these are population-based
individuals so they're not demented
they're just normal or they have mild
cognitive impairment so as you can see
when
you have a good look they've value of
1.2 or 1.3 5 you have absolutely not
much in your cortex so your gray matter
is pretty much let me show use an arrow
here the gray matter here it's pretty
pretty it does not have a lot of amyloid
deposition but once you move on to 1.6
what happens is you start seeing more
gray matter amyloid uptake so tip uptake
in the cockpit cortices neocortex and it
gets more severe as you move to 1.9 to
2.5 so typically when a patient comes in
and you get a pip scan the scans look
from 1.0 to about 3.0 if you are 1.5 or
below clinically you're you're assumed
to have very little or insignificant
amount of amyloid deposition but about
1.5 you're supposed to have you you
would have significant amount of amyloid
deposition so if you look at controls
let's say you had a group of controls
and scan them you would find that about
30% of controls have positive amyloid
scans so above the cut point of 1.5
which means that they do have
significant amount of amyloid deposition
but they have not expressed clinical
symptoms so far and if you look at mild
cognitive impact patients it is said
that about 60 to 70 percent of mild
cognitive impairments have amyloid
deposition saying that they have mild
cognitive impairment due to amyloid or
Alzheimer's disease pathology and
typically all Alzheimer's disease
patients have positive amyloid scans the
cut point 1 point 5 is for specifically
tip scans but this this cut point can be
translated to other scans as well as it
is a little bit of pure freedom at wall
one thing to notice that is a new
project that is getting started which is
known as the central art project and the
goal of the project is to come up with a
common cutoff for all pip scans so they
want to make it so that 0 corresponds to
control and 100 corresponds to all sinus
disease patients
so it's easy for clinicians to use that
entire scale and determine if someone
has a lommers disease level of amyloid
deposition or they have normal level of
amyloid deposition and what how does an
are deposit in general and in an elderly
brain so this is the Australian imaging
and biomarker flagship study but they
studied cognitively normal subjects mild
cognitive impairment disease subjects
over a really long period of time and
they found that as I am allowed the
position is a slow and protracted
process and probably takes about a
couple of decades to reach the levels of
assange disease level of amyloid
deposition we followed that up with a
study from our group where we try to
plot if you look at the first plot you
see the rate of amyloid deposition
plotted against baseline amyloid so up
till a level about 2.0 there is an
acceleration of the position so as
people and enter this Alzheimers to see
spectrum initially this is a rapid
deposition of amyloid and then there's a
deceleration where slowing of the
deposition so if you translate it to
time on the x-axis and degree of amyloid
deposition on the y-axis you can really
see that it's a sigmoid shaped curve so
initially there's an acceleration of
amyloid deposition and then there is a
slowing down and plateauing caused the
amyloid deposition in in a brain and
what was interesting from the study was
we were able to come up with the time
period during which it happens so
there's a 15-year time interval on an
average in two people so some people it
might take 20 years or some people it
might take 10 years depending on the
genetics but about 15 year of an average
window which is a large therapeutic
window for secondary prevention trials
and it's really promising and for in
terms of employing prevention trials to
delay the onset of the season I'll
briefly talk about CSF and fdg-pet now
CSF a be the one to forty two levels
reflect deposition of a beta
slack's so if you have low CSF a bit of
under 242 levels that means there's more
amyloid in the brain so because it's
deposited the degree of CSF a bit of 142
in the CSF is lower and so CSF total tau
levels reflect active axonal neuronal
damage so someone with head trauma or
brain injury have really high highly
significant amount of total tau levels
as you can see as you go from controls
to MCI MC at 80 a B the levels decrease
and total power level increase
clinically the ratio that is used to
measure measure the degree of disease
using CSF is the ratio between total
power to a bit of one 242 which
increases as you go from control to MCI
280 the cut points used in CSF
biomarkers have been established using
the ADI data as well as aadmi which is a
language disease neuroimaging initiative
you hear from dr. Mike whiner later and
he's been hitting the Adney initiative
and it has provided us with valuable
data to look at what happens in the
different biomarkers so based on autopsy
confirmed data from University of
Pennsylvania the cut points that are
clinically used right now or CSF a bit
of one to forty two levels less than one
ninety to indicate alzheimers disease
pathology as well as CSF total levels
greater than ninety three if you also
have amyloid deposition indicates
Alzheimer's disease pathology looking at
FTC PET scans we have worked quite a bit
on fdg-pet but I just present briefly
one slide here on fdg-pet
it basically measures glucose uptake and
as you can see metabolic deficits in the
parietal lobe shown here parietal lobe
and a little bit of the occipital lobe
shows tau mediated neuronal injury and
dysfunction in FDB PET scans of
Alzheimer's disease patients moving on
to structural MRI
it measures neuronal injury and it
measures the new regeneration due to a
sinus disease starts in the hippocampus
and spreads to the end
neocortex so hippocampal structure is
right here and as you can see controls
have an intact hippocampal volume but
when you move to mild cognitive
impairment the hippocampal volume
decreases and there's more fluid
surrounding the medial temporal lobe
soon as I moved as I'm cc's you not only
have significant hippocampal atrophy but
you also have ventricular atrophy as
well as total entire neocortex shrinking
and making the brain smaller and the
degree of fluid increasing why is MRI
important MRI is important because it
captures prostate is really well off the
280 pathologies that we talked about
earlier one miss plaques second-most
neurofibrillary tangles the
stereotypical pattern of progression and
a widely accepted staging system for NSD
was formerly the but by Brock and
brought in 91 it has been extensively
used for pathological ad staging and
what MRI captures is these drug stages
so it makes it really easy to assess the
degree of Alzheimer's disease in the
brain so why is it important to capture
brock stages in this study by dr.
engleson you see that a beta as we
already saw earlier is an early process
NF t is a later process and this NF t
deposition called it strongly with the
cognitive change so the progression from
prodromal Alzheimer's disease in
controls to MCI to AD
and the advantage of MRI is that it's
strongly correlates with clinical
symptoms as well as has the low
variability of M our signal due to high
reproduce ability we have been working
for the last couple of decades on the
extracting information from MRI scans
the most simplistic way has been visual
assessment when you look at a scan and
say hey the middle temporal lobe is
really after fit or not have a traffic
and give a scale of 1 to 5 the second
count method that has been employed in
the 90s has been looking at hippocampal
volume and
drawing delineating the edges of the
hippocampus and measuring the degree of
hippocampal volume that exists in a
person recently in the last decade
they're more sophisticated methods that
have been used to quantify voxel based
changes in Alzheimer's disease well the
second one the second one which is the
multi walks with pattern information
methods which provide individual subject
diagnosis is what we've been focusing on
so the idea is when a new incoming
patient comes into your clinic you get
an MRI scan and you get a single number
and you're able to diagnose that person
is having a language disease kind of
atrophy or not so the particular score
that we have been working with is known
in structure of normality index score
stands course and here's a slide it here
is a study in which we try to correlate
it with Brock stages and found that
Stan's course which basically hones on
the areas of the incoming MRI scan where
there's significant amount of atrophy
and we found that this time score
increases with Brock stage and that's a
really good correlation which makes it a
very good biomarker to use and Stan
scores above zero indicate that
someone's brain is more Alzheimer
disease like and Stan scores below zero
is indicate that the subjects brain is
more control like the cut point here is
zero the other longitudinal MRI based
measures that are available for
measuring change over time have to
confidence so you have two scans and you
need to determine how fast that person
is progressing in terms of the disease
progression so the two components of
that first is you need to register both
the scans and you need to summarize the
change the most simplistic method that
has been employed by the Alzheimer's
disease community is boundary shift it
integral where you register both the
scans and try to get the degree of
overall ventricular volume expansion or
brain volume shrinkage so as you can see
they're shown in green and red on this
this first image more sophisticated
methods because we are getting more
more computationally intensive as well
as computers are becoming faster is
using walks of level differences where
you look to scans and say exactly which
was the spot where there's an expansion
taking place and how fast is it taking
place in this person and can we predict
what's gonna happen in that person so
for this method such as TB m or tensor
base morphometry methods are developed
and as you can see in the image you can
really pinpoint to where there's a
significant amount of so the inferior
male middle temporal lobe and medial
temporal lobe shows significant amount
of voxel level changes indicating that
probably this person has is not a really
rapid part because the scans were about
one-year different the conductor's study
to just test the hypothesis that if
biomarkers particular biomarkers
correlate with disease progression
better than the others using an Lea data
so on the in the first column you see
annual change in cognitive scores and in
the rest of the columns you see changes
first one is the annual annual change in
ventricular volume based on MRI scans
second one is annual change in CSF a bit
of one to forty two levels and the third
one is annual change in total power
levels as you can see in MC eyes and as
iris disease patients both MMSE and CDR
some of boxes which are global scores of
cognition collate strongly with the
ventricular volume change indicating
that probably MRI is a much better track
tracker of progression compared to CSF
or other scans so the take-home message
from part one is first amyloid the
position more than 30 percent of
cognitively normal subjects have amyloid
deposition it's a really slow process
over decades about 15 years from the
time when there is in significant amount
of deposition to this significant amount
of deposition amyloid deposition does
not correlate strongly with commission
what correlates strongly with cognition
cognition is near
the biomarkers and they're excellent for
the C's tracking moving on the biomarker
cascade so we talked about Al's Imus
disease biomarkers having a cascade next
they do have a cascade because I'm
allowed the position is early and slow
and changes in tau as well as changes in
MRI are much later and follow closely to
the cognitive decline so since the
pathology itself manifests in the
temporal sequence biomarkers of a
temporal sequence field and this has
been confirmed by several other studies
which have said that amyloid deposition
happens years before the onset of
clinical symptoms both the Dyan study as
well as the able study have shown that
before the onset of clinical symptoms as
you can see in red on the second second
figure this line starts much earlier
before the onset of symptoms which is
shown by the number zero here so why do
we really care about biomarker cascade
in the context of protective mechanisms
the first point is that diagnostic
criteria recently have changed
significantly
now they incorporate information from
biomarker cascade so it's important to
understand the cascade second thing is
that the protective mechanisms might
cause different Cascades so someone who
have four more protective mechanisms in
place might have a completely different
cascade from someone who do not have as
many protective mechanisms in place and
the third reason why we need to
understand the biomarker cascade is that
when will the interventions work so
either it's a lifestyle intervention or
a drug intervention when will it work
when can you provide maximum protection
for patients so that's why we need to
understand the biomarker cascade I just
want to briefly change the pace and talk
about what's been used in the clinic
currently so there was a really large
initiative called the ni a la mercè
Association criteria so National
Institute of Aging and I'm as associate
criteria where they came up with
completely new criteria for diagnosis
and prognosis of MCI ad as well as
freaking mental a lease of controls and
I'm showing you the slide from there the
MCI diagnosis and prognosis according to
the new criteria you are likely to be
high likelihood of being MCI due to a D
if you have positive amyloid scan or a
positive CSF biomarker or you've had
positive CSF over tau fdg-pet
or MRI scans why have the introduce this
new criteria for diagnosing MCI the
reason is because in a very short period
of time sale here people who are high
likelihood of MCI due to a B because of
positivity of either of these biomarkers
100% of them are likely to progress to
80 and about 2.3 times there's a higher
risk of progression to 80 and those who
have high likelihood of MCI due to AD
compared to any of the other groups so
this is a really key step forward in the
clinic in order to translate the ideas
that are being developed based on the
biomarker cascade into the clinic I
wanted to briefly touch on the
preclinical stages of Alzheimer's
disease because this is really important
to understand so the new and IA criteria
say that if you take cognitively normal
subjects and use biomarkers and early
subjects you would find that a lot of
them have something going on in their
brain but they're still able to function
normally so the new criteria basically
give preclinical Alzheimers to see
stages and cognitively normal subjects
so that it helps us understand and helps
us predict what's going to happen in the
near future so if we took a
population-based sample from Mayo Clinic
study of aging MCSA which is the sample
we've been working with about 600 people
and we found that people who fall under
stage 0 which is they don't have
anything wrong with their Alzheimer's
disease biomarkers are only 43% of the
general population which is an extremely
low number
and a lot of people fall under something
happening in their brain or not and
about 16 plus 12 plus the 3% who fought
about 30% in total who fall under stages
one two and three of us very much the
status they are on the path of
developing Alzheimer's disease sometime
in the near future the near future could
be if you have stage 3 then your future
could be five years if your state at the
beginning of stage one it could be 15
years but if you know the biomarkers
something is wrong with your biomarkers
you are either on stage one two or three
so if you're if you am alert the
position of the brain your stage one if
you amyloid the position on the brain
and you know no changes in the brain
your stage two your stage three if
you're a Millar in the brain
you know engineer in the brain as well
as you cognitive impairment in the brain
then your stage 3 so all these three
stages together put you at a higher risk
of developing Alzheimer's disease or MCI
compared to stage zero but there's
nothing wrong in your brain this really
helps us target people and try to
intervene earlier and provide diagnosis
as well as provide better prognosis to
these folks this slide again drives from
the point that if you are in stage 0 is
less likely to progress MCI and 80 in a
short interval of time it's been 15
months of time but if you are in stage 1
2 3 you have a pretty high likelihood of
progressing to MCI or AD which makes it
a good time to intervene and try to make
changes to lifestyle this is a very nice
line which summarizes what's going on
right now all the trials and Alzheimer's
disease later in the disease process
have failed so tertiary prevention
trials which have targeted to improve
the symptoms after this amyloid
deposition as well as his onset of
symptoms I have really failed so most of
the folks right now we're running large
clinical trials at the Apia for and
Diane
trials unit have moved forward to the
juncture of primary to secondary
prevention for example a for trial
a full trial images cognitively normal
subjects and targets those who have
amyloid the position
the brain so somewhere between stage 1 2
& 3 and try to try to see if treatment
at that point will really help delay the
onset of dementia or mild come through
impairment solicitors are not out yet
but this is a really exciting time of
history in a sinus disease drug
discovery and implementation because in
the next four or five years we really
see large jumps in the way the drug the
disease is treated and how only the C's
is identified so the take-home message
from part two is that biomarkers have a
temporal sequencing information is now
being applied to thick diseases early
and non demented elderly which is really
important because early diagnosis can
help with early prevention and as we go
on more and more a number of people
agree that there's a right stage for the
intervention and it's too late once the
clinical symptoms are have onset so
earlier is better coming to the last
part of my talk which is the crux of my
research cognitive reserve I wanted to
show you this slide which trying to
drives home why it's important to delay
the onset of Alzheimer's disease so
usamos association trajectory report
came up with a trajectory of Alzheimer's
disease
subjects we are going to foresee in the
next thirty five years so by about 2050
you would see if 13.5 million people
being diagnosed by Alzheimer's disease
let's say miraculously we came up with a
drug all-in lifestyle intervention which
could delay the onset of by at least
five years then the total the trajectory
would drop by 40% which is a significant
amount of drop given the amount of
impact as imes disease has on the on
Medicare on the part from the public
health perspective it's significant
amount of savings and it will prevent
the epidemic of Alzheimer s disease by
2050
so to answer the question of how can we
prevent not using drugs but by lifestyle
interventions how can we prevent the
start of Alzheimer this alzheimers
disease we need we everybody ask the
questions
why do some subjects of Alzheimer's
disease pathology as I stated earlier
thirty percent of people with amyloid
remains cognitively normal during their
life but some of them that look dementia
so the common term that is used to
explain this phenomena is that people
have higher cognitive reserve or more
protective mechanisms in place so when
you feel protective mechanisms what
would you what do you mean probably they
have higher IQ higher education they
have have been engaging in physical
activities or they've been engaging and
cognitive activities and how come
someone with a brain amyloid scan on the
left side
well there's minimal deposition and
someone's brain with significant amount
of amyloid the position shown on the
right side how come they both perform
the same level of cognitive performance
so it's a mystery right so what how is
that possible and what are the
mechanisms through which these folks are
on the right are able to cope up with it
so there are other examples as well so
all the three people here probably
around at the same level of cognitive
performance but the person on the left
has no amyloid intact brain the person
in the middle has significant amyloid in
that brain the third person has a little
bit of amyloid but really atrophied
brain structures how come they all
perform at the same level the idea is
that people have different cascades so
there let's say take two subjects the
degrees of pathology for the same
clinical expression these two subjects
have completely different Cascades the
subject a needs really high amount of
amyloid and neuronal injury to move them
from mild cognitive impairment or
dementia where a subject be at half the
amount of amyloid or neuronal injury
they move from mild cognitive impairment
dementia
paper by Stern Show the same thing
someone but high school are higher than
high school alzheimers disease patient
had significantly worse brain metabolism
compared to someone with low low below
highschool education the several papers
that have talked about biomarkers being
more of normal in subjects with high
cognitive reserve so all of us know and
from the research in the past couple of
decades that contrib reserve an
Alzheimer's disease delays onset the new
frontier is how does it delay onset and
what can we do to delay onset the
several hypotheses out there about how
it delays the onset of Alzheimer's
disease the first hypothesis is that
cognitive Reserve has an independent
effect on cognition as I said earlier it
improves someone's cognition it's no
effect on pathology the second
hypothesis is that it lowers the
accumulation of the polity someone is
thinking more they probably had less
pathology is the belief the third
hypothesis is that it interacts with
pathology somehow people with higher
cognitive reserve are able to reduce the
effects of pathology on cognition so
there's an interaction between both
these boxes causing and improved
cognition cognitive performance so I
just wanted to briefly summarize two of
the studies where we investigated the
effect of cognitive reserve on the by by
a biomarker cascade we had two
independent studies completely different
populations completely different
cognitive measurements and cognitive
reserve variables as well as different
biomarkers that were used in study one
we use data from Annie and we took
everybody who had a CSF biomarker as
well as MRI biomarker available and we
used a large number of cognitive our
outcomes to measure what was happening
cognitively in these subjects and we
used number of errors on American
national adult reading tests or a mark
as a measure of cognitive reserve
typically it's used in the measure of
verbal IQ in a person and what we found
from the study were very interesting one
list we found no correlation between
biomarker and cognitive reserve
available so someone with higher verbal
IQ don't necessarily have lower lower
pathology in their brain that's what we
found the second thing we found was
there was no effect of cognitive reserve
available on the relationship between
biomarkers of cognition what does that
mean each one of these graphs show a
biomarker on the x-axis and the
cognitive outcome on the y-axis as you
can see someone who's performing on an
average is shown in blue and if they
have higher or lower cognitive reserve
the curve is just shifted up or down but
the overall effect there is no
interaction so this is an independent
effect of cognitive reserve available on
the relationships but there's no
interaction to explain this in detail I
go to the second study where we looked
at cognitively normal subjects and mild
cognitive impairment at population-based
study and we found that we use global
z-score as a cognitive reserve outcome
and what was interesting in this
population was we recorded what their
lifestyle was so what the current
lifestyle was what the lifestyle mice
lifestyle was based on their education
job score and we had a cognitive
questionnaire so we were we asked what
exactly they did how many times a week
did they read how many times in the week
they play music how many times in the
week did they do social activities on an
average over the last 12 months and we
also recorded physical activity
lifestyle so how strenuous work did they
do that they work out every day how many
days of the week they do medium want of
work and so on a really long
questionnaire to record what exactly
they were doing in their life and we use
two independent methods first was we use
simple correlations between biomarkers
and lifestyle variables where we found
no relationship between the two second
is that these structural equation models
or path analysis to evaluate the
associations between lifestyle
activities imaging biomarkers and global
cognition so these are the results of
the path analysis the box are shown on
the left here our boxes that our
cognitive reserve variables so lifestyle
intellectual activity how mentally
active have you been based on your
education and the job that you have been
doing second is we leave the current
intellectual activity based on the
activities you are currently doing and
then we looked at current physical
activity and said do any of these
influence global global functioning of a
person the answer was yes education
occupation had a significant impact on
your performance so if your if your
early life had really a lot of
enrichment intellectual enrichment then
you tend to perform really well later in
life your current intellectual lifestyle
did have an effect but the effect was
not as large as the effect of Education
and occupation your current physical
activity did not have a significant
impact on your global performance so
this data kind of lends support to the
fact that as education or intellectual
enrichment is to the mind physical
activity to your heart so Alzheimer's
disease is a disease of the brain so it
was a little surprising but not that
surprising that current physical
activity did not improve global
functioning what was interesting was
none of these gray lines that are shown
here were significant so right here you
can see that lifestyle intellectual
activity did not influence the amyloid
burden so if you're more education and
occupation of you have a higher
education and occupations that does not
necessarily mean that you have lesser
amyloid burden in the brain and so none
of these gray lines were significant but
biomarkers by themselves were affecting
the global cognition which is well
unlisted because you have more amyloid
deposition you have lesser hippocampal
volume and you have less glucose uptake
then you have worse cognitive
performance
so this is a model summarizing the
lifestyle data where we talked about the
biomarker cascade right so upstream
biomarkers of Alzheimer's disease
pathology cost downstream come to
decline but what lifestyle activity does
is it moves the cognitive decline curve
in terms of time flows our way to the
biomarker good so if you have low
lifestyle activity then the AMA the time
taken for you to reach a particular
level of cognitive performance drops by
lambda
- or it increases by lambda plus this
was the major finding of this paper but
our next question was how much is the
time how much can we how much is the
time and how much time can we buy by by
by engaging in lifestyle activities so
just briefly summarize in one study our
study found that hypothesis 1 is true
where there's an independent effect of
on cognition our work as as well as the
nun study and the religious artists auto
study coming out of Rush Medical Center
in Chicago basically proved that
hypothesis 1 is true but there are some
other studies which smaller amount of
data well which have which have found
evidence for hypothesis 2 and 3 as well
coming back a full circle this is what
we believe is happening with cognitive
reserve there's a blue a red curve
there's a dotted black curve both
indicating amyloid the position and MRI
changes but cognitive reserve determines
when and how much time is there between
the red curve and the blue curve shown
by this this Delta a beta minus delta
MRI so this distance is on an average
let's say five years lower cognitive
reserve might decrease the distance by
one year to one year or increase the
high cognitive reserve might increase
the distance 10 years so our next
question is how many years and what do
we do to protect and how many years can
we do
the onset of cognitive impairment for
this we have been studying about 2009
demented subjects and who completed
intellectual lifestyle measures and
baseline and underwent at least one
clinical follow-up so some of them had
follow-up to up to seven years so we've
been tracking people from 2004 onwards
and trying to see how their education
occupation as well as mid late life
cognitive activities affect their
cognitive project-- reason for this work
we decided that we will divide the
intellectual lifestyle enrichment into
two components one is education and
occupation which is early life
conditioning second is mid late life
cognitive activity something that they
do later in life that can impact their
cognitive electrics and this is how the
trajectory slope first of all we have to
divide these by gender as well as a
ponytails so people work at buoy a fork
who are employed for carriers
significantly decline faster than those
who's not happy for the second thing is
that men's appear to perform a little
lower than women significantly lower
than women stating that each of them
have a different trajectories and in
order to determine what happens in a
person mean it's important to know their
gender as well as a four-state status
you'll appreciate that the top curve is
in someone with high education and
higher occupation as well as someone who
is engaging in a lot of activities so
they're way better off than everybody
else because they have significantly
higher cognitive performance than the
rest of the curves the worst curve is
the red curve which is shown at the very
bottom these subjects are people with
low education occupation and have not
engaged in a lot of a lot of cognitive
activities and when I say a lot what
does it mean it's a lot means at least
three times a week
therefore the read papers newspapers or
an average they've done three or four
activities such as read books play music
engaged in conversations
organizational evens and so on so that
means that is high high cognitive
activity in someone so the red curve
shows in people who have not engaged in
a lot of activities and have not
benefited from them
this is the real plot which drives home
the point so if you take someone from
the general population who's eighty year
old so I've only focused on e4 carriers
and you can see that the the bottommost
curve here bottom most line here
indicates somewhat the just to go back
the y axis indicates the degree of
education and occupation
so there's low education occupation
medium education and occupation and
higher education and occupation so the
curve shown here at the bottom is shown
in red someone with low education and
occupation who's eight year old may be
developing mild cognitive impairment by
the time they're 82 but if they engaged
in higher education so a higher
intellectual activity then they can
delay their onset to about five years so
two years to the cognitive impairment
but engaging in high activities moves
this curve further down and you could
probably not develop cognitive
impairment till you're 85 which is a
significant jump and then if you look at
someone with higher education on
occupation they're very off they're
probably eight years away from
developing at least eight years away
from developing cognitive impairment so
we're talking about men here solid
colors are shown for men but if they are
engaging someone with a high education
occupation are engaging in cognitive
activity it moves that curve further
down here giving them some more years
that they can remain cognitively normal
so this has been an exciting area of
research where we are able to provide
guidelines of how much protection can we
get by engaging and cognitive activities
so the take-home message from part three
is that studies provide evidence that
Congress reserved delays the
sort of dementia not only arts but
others and we found that cognitive
reserve does not influence the
expression of AD pathophysiology second
is that the effect on biomarker cascade
is that if NU'EST cognitive decline
curve down relative to the biomarker
curves which is really helpful in
delaying the onset of the season
specifically with the new studies that
we're coming out with we are able to
come up with time time to cognitive
impairment numbers so and it looks like
lifetime and lifetime intellectual
enrichment might delay the onset of
cognitive impairment and can be used as
a pretty successful preventive
intervention to reduce the impending
dementia epidemic future directions are
that we plan to develop more sensitive
in vivo biomarkers which could
objectively measure the degree of
pathology in a person we need to come up
with everybody needs to work on coming
up with neuropsychological tests that
provide detectable decline in cognition
irrespective an individual level of
cognitive result it's believed that
people with higher education and
occupation have mechanisms in place
where they're able to perform were on
desperate they do have something going
on in the brain so can we use better
tests to detect that the third that we
need better proxies for cognitive
reserve and we need to study the
mechanisms and younger subjects are
elderly with minimal Authority which is
very important and we need larger cause
long follow-ups and serial biomarker
measurements antemortem and near
pathological details at post-mortem to
further improve our understanding
I'd like to thank the lab I've been
working with and the generous grant
support that I've received in the last
couple of years and this water to
indicate that to obtain CME credits you
no need to go and answer the questions
related to these the presentation given
here I will move on to questions
so the first question was could the
stands could be used evaluate from path
studies like the study of her diagrams
to see if it explains they cannot see
the question clearly yeah so to see if
it explained subjects and maintain
cognitive function even with significant
plug deposition the answer is yes and
the answer is yes we have we have looked
at people with the stands called people
who have Alzheimer's have plugged the
position but they didn't have
significant amount of neurofibrillary
tangles and seem that Stan scores are
relatively closer to zero midpoint
between AD and controls and they're more
sophisticated metals that we've been
working on where we can actually detect
what happens in these people and
probably do a better job at detecting
amyloid versus for NST related pathology
earlier so the second question was are
there any molecules to induce alien mice
yes they're transgenic mice that have as
amyloid pathology that that have been
that have been studied a lot so there's
a lot of research animal research -
research that have not been closely
involved with so I can't completely
answer the question but there are
studies and transgenic mice where the
induce and try to see if the drugs the
first level of trials will work in mice
or not
third question is the it is not here why
you interpret the failure of clinical
trials as being due to providing the
therapy to rate rather than the
possibility of choosing an appropriate
therapeutic target so the belief is that
so if you go back to the paper written
by Risa Sperling as well as the recent
papers that have come out this one good
paper by Jeffrey Cummings that I've
talked about so when is the right time
so most of the most of the trials have
been in subjects with mild AD and it is
repeatedly been shown by biomarkers that
if you take someone with mild AD already
have significant amount of brain damage
so but 80% of them had really small
hippocampus hippocampus as well as that
significant amount of amyloid the
position which might be really late so
the the the spiral down to you know
significant damage to the brain has
already been set and that's the reason
why we believe that providing therapy
too late is probably not that helps less
providing therapy early earlier in the
days the fourth question is most area
work have always been beta amyloid
are there other pathways to check so the
answer is yes there are other pathways
to check right now the most in vogue
theory is beta amyloid because all the
data supports that but there are other
theories for example there's one theory
which basically says metabolic deficits
probably it's some kind of diabetes of
the brain that's what onsets the
Alzheimer disease process or there's
another belief that ad is just
accelerated aging so someone just ages
faster due to their genetics and other
things in place so there are theories
out there so as I answered any link
between diabetes in AD yes there is a
belief that ad is the diabetes of the
brain there there are several reviews
that are actually going to detail
about metabolic deficits and diabetes
causing the onset of AD in a tea being
insulin resistance of the brain so I
could post some links pointing to these
studies but there is significant
research in that area as well in your
the next question is that in your
intellectual lifestyle activity
correlation analysis shouldn't life's
lifetime physical activity be an
important variable due to its effect on
global inflammation biomarkers that is
true that's what we actually expected to
see but unfortunately we did not see any
such relationships because I think other
variables so what happened was cognitive
activity is highly correlated with
physical activity it's a highly
correlated with education which is
understandable because people are right
higher educated probably engage in more
physical activity but once you take all
the variables together we were surprised
that physical activity effect was
extremely small and what was driving the
entire analysis was intellectual
enrichment so the answer is maybe it
does have an effect but given the other
variables it seems like the effect is
really small and we didn't see a car
since it wasn't a causal effect so we
didn't put people and trials for
physical activity and then measure their
improvement which we plan to do in the
future but in the study that we had
where it was an observational study we
did not see that lifetime intellectual
activity was an important variable so a
question number seven was heavy image
individuals with Down syndrome and
compared the pathology and cognitive
reserve against a more neurotypical
population actually the answer is no our
focus has been population-based sample
and we have not had a cohort in there
who have had Down syndrome and older
people as expected because the folk we
have been focusing so far for the last
ten years image people from sixty
6570 so our core population has been 70
to 90 but we have been moving the
population down to 50 to 70 and even
lower so I expect that in the next
decade or so we'll have a reasonable
amount of cohort to look at people with
Down syndrome the next question was it
was a suggestion saying that the
grandfather had dementia and because
they were active his whole life that
helped them a lot and actually that's
really good and I think it really shows
the power of engaging in being mentally
stimulated and engaging and
intellectually enriching activities it
really does help so and I'd be President
speaking to you if you wanted to talk
more about it so what are the seller
accepts the next question was what are
the cellular substrates of cognitive
reserve could drugs induced cognitive
reserve there is a belief that yes you
could improve cognitive performance by
taking certain drugs but our our outlook
has then always lifestyle enrichment and
things we could do which are which make
I would say performance better but we
have not looked at drugs that induce
comment of reserve but a lot of things I
mean cognitive reserve is just not IQ or
it's not cognitive activities and so on
if you saw there's a recent study which
talked about sleep if you sleep better
you if you try to get enough sleep let's
say you perform a lot better than not
getting enough sleep especially when
you're older so I believe that there are
other natural ways in which you can pump
up your cognitive reserve and that would
really help you delay the onset of
Alzheimer's disease so the next question
is very interesting which is how about
Alzheimer's disease in younger subjects
can the results be applied in these
cases so some part of the study that we
haven't shown here we had a paper in our
annals of Neurology in which I try to
investigate one genetics dust you so
people who have Alzheimer's disease at a
younger age let's say 65 our Lord you
see a lot of people who have who are 55
and they have really severe amount of
Alzheimer's disease so in those patients
the there are two things in balance -
genetics so multiple things but two of
the things that we're talking about is
genetics and Alzheimer's disease helped
by cognitive reserve in the younger
subjects the genetics outweighs like it
is very outweighing the benefits of
cognitive reserve though we have not
studied people younger as deceased
patients and younger subjects but you
can see that the effect would be much
smaller so let's take a for carrier
sources known in non in four carriers
efore carriers just because of the
genetics they actually develop
Alzheimer's disease five to seven years
earlier and maybe the benefit if you
compare the times in which cognitive
reserve helps them people who are Nani
for our carriers the protection is about
seven to eight years whereas people who
were Evo carriers as you saw earlier the
protection was just three years so maybe
you would benefit but not as much the
next question was speaking of bio market
cascades have they examined which
biomarker groups appear together more
often you mean to say which of them
changed together of causing a sinus
disease that would be amyloid total tau
all the biomarkers that I showed fdg-pet
as well as structural MRI
other means nutrients known to induce a
prevent AD yes actually there's a lot of
research on Mediterranean diet being
really good and preventing the onset of
Alzheimer's disease and lowering the
risk of developing my account of
impairment in the literature that you
could look up could cognitive reserve
support the concept of using
regenerative therapies the answer is we
are working on on these theories and
trying to understand exactly the
mechanism
mechanisms through which cognitive
reserves can help so this is still an
open question but there is some animal
based studies my space studies that have
shown that probably counter reserve can
help the last questions are what types
of cognitive activities do you suggest a
person with moderate ad should do now to
slow down the progression I would say
anything that word anything that would
engage them in keeping them mentally
active so right now there are a lot of
computer-based training methods there's
some really good ones out there and then
now there's a belief that if you have a
more mind body balanced kind of
complementary medicine special yoga or
Tai Chi they can probably help there
they're not large comprehensive studies
as yet but there's a belief that doing
anything to keep a more balanced mind
and keeping your brain mentally active
can help this progression of Alzheimer's
disease has anyone considered the
possibility that the cognitive benefit
of physical activity may be closely
related with the increase in cognitive
and motor functions that have to be
coordinated by the brain as in
competitive sports or non non
competitive spend swimming
not not really closely but there is art
Kramer from UIUC who has looked at
physical activity helping the
functioning of the brain I think we need
more clinical trials kind of things
where we engage let's say 100 or 200
people and see the benefits before and
after and see how how better did I get
how better do the does their wiring of
the brain get next question was what is
the role of herbal formulations in this
disease I am NOT an expert to answer
this question so I'm going to skip this
any non correlation between specific
professional carrier and incidents of AD
so in this is a really interesting
question but we try to the in the study
that I did about occupation right so we
try to die to divide people between 1 to
6 and said that hey if you have really
intensive intensive carriers such as
being a doctor or being professional
executor and so on you're really highly
rated on the scale versus not being
highly rated on the scale and we saw
that there is a significant correlation
between someone's professional carrier
how much brain do they use versus the
incidence of any in this scale we
actually did not take physical activity
as much into account so someone is a
manual laborer we rated them low and we
just rated them on how much mental
stimulation do they get during their job
and we found that this really strong
correlation of how much mental
stimulation you get through your
professional carrier versus the inter
incidence of AD tha possible benefit I
cannot say that because I'm not an
expert in it so I think I've answered I
need all the questions if there to be a
one minute left
thank you if they're no more